Let's do some more matrix
multiplication examples,
because I think it is all about
seeing as many examples
as possible.
So let's do what may seem to be
a more difficult problem,
and it might not be even
clear that we can
multiply these matrices.
And maybe that's the first thing
we should think about.
So let's say I wanted to
multiply the matrix-- I'll do
it relatively small so we
don't run out of space.
3, 1, 2, minus 2, 0, 5.
Let's say I want to multiply
that times the matrix, minus
1, 0, 2, 3, 5, 5.
I'm just making up
these numbers.
So the first thing you might
be wondering is, well can I
even multiply these matrices?
Because you know from the
first video we did on
matrices, that you can't
add these two matrices.
This term corresponds to this
one; this one corresponds to
this one; but this term
corresponds to nothing over
here so you couldn't add or
subtract these matrices.
So the question is, can I
multiply these matrices?
Well, what did we learn about
multiplying matrices?
We know that, for example, if
this is going to result in
some matrix--
However we don't know even what
the dimensions are yet
until we work through this
example, although there is a
quick way for figuring it out.
So this first term here, the
upper left term, where does it
get its row information from
and where does it get its
column information from?
Well, it gets its row
information from here.
So it is essentially this
row times which column?
Times this column, right?
And we can actually take the dot
product of this row vector
and this column vector because
they have the same length.
This is a column vector but it
has a length of 3, right?
But it's a 3 by 1, it has
three elements in it.
And this is a 1 by 3 row vector,
but it also has three
elements in it.
So we actually can take the
dot product or we can
multiply these two.
And similarly we can multiply
this times this whole thing to
get this term right here.
And we can multiply this thing
times this thing to get this
term, and then this
thing times that
term to get that term.
So it actually turns out that
you can-- so what kind of a
matrix is this?
Let's call it that this is
matrix-- let me switch to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So this is matrix A.
And what are it's dimensions?
It has 2 rows, 1, 2,
and 3 columns.
So it's a 2 by 3 matrix.
We're multiplying it times B.
And what are B's dimensions?
Well, it has 3 rows, 1, 2, 3.
So it is a 3 by-- and how many
columns does it have?
1, 2-- 2 matrix.
So it turns out that we can
multiply two matrices.
You can say that the number--
if, on the first matrix-- the
number of columns is equal to
the number of rows in the
second matrix.
So here, 2 by 3 times 3
by 2, we can multiply.
For example, we could
have multiplied, if
this is matrix C.
I don't know if I take
so much time to keep
bolding these things.
And I don't care how
many rows it has.
It can have n rows,
n times a columns.
I can multiply it times
matrix D, as long as
matrix D has a rows.
As long as you can say these
two inner numbers are the
same, right?
This 3 is the same as 3.
And why does that matter,
what was the logic?
Because this row will have 3
elements because there's 3
columns, and each column
vector here will have 3
elements, because
there's 3 rows.
That's where intuition comes
from, but if you had to do it
really quickly you say 2 by 3,
3 by 2, this number is equal
to that number, I
can multiply.
So let me clear up some
space and let's do the
multiplication.
Let's do some multiplication.
I'm debating where I should do
it, actually I think I should
do it down here maybe because
I'll have more space.
So let me do it down there;
I don't have to
erase anything else.
So let me get some
space ready.
OK, this will take up
a lot of space.
So to get this row 1, column
1 element, what do I do?
I multiply this vector
times this vector.
I take the dot product, right?
So it's 3 times negative 1-- I'm
just going to write it all
-- 3 times minus 1, plus 1
times 0, plus 2 times 2.
There, we got the first term.
So the second term here,
what am I going to do?
I'm going to multiply that
vector times that row vector
times this column vector.
And I think you're getting the
hang of this, and really the
hardest part about this is
staying focused and not making
a careless mistake.
And not getting it confused
with rows and
columns and all that.
It just sends blood to your
brain, but it's not
that hard, I think.
So what do we do?
We multiply this row vector
times this column vector to
get row 1, column 2, right?
Because this row,
row 1, column 2.
3 times 3, plus 1 times 5,
plus 2 times 5, right.
We're just multiplying the
corresponding terms, the third
term times the third term, the
second term times the second
term, the first term times
the first term.
Although, in this case they're
going down, in this case
they're going left and right.
Oh, we add them all up.
OK, so now we're in the second
row, and we get our row
information from the first
vector-- and let me do a red
that I never use because I think
it's kind of tacky, this
red right here.
So I'm going to multiply
this row vector
times this column vector.
So it's minus 2 times minus
1, plus 0 times 0,
plus 5 times 2.
We're almost done.
Let me see-- I don't like this
color at all-- and now we're
going to multiply this row,
because we're in this bottom
row, we're in row 2, column
2, to row 2, column 2.
So it's minus 2 times 3, plus
0 times 5, plus 5 times 5.
And then if we simplify, let's
see, this is minus 3 plus 0,
plus 4, so this-- if I have
my math correct--
simplifies to 1.
9 plus 5 is 14, plus 10 is 24.
This is 1, 24, and then minus 2
times minus 1 is 2, plus 10,
so this is 12.
And then minus 2 times 3 is
minus 6, plus 10-- this is 0--
so minus 6 plus 10 is 4.
So that's interesting.
When I multiplied a 2 by 3
vector times a 3 by 2 vector,
what did I get?
I got a 2 by 2 matrix.
A 2 by 3 matrix, a 2 by 3 times
3 by 2 matrix, I got a 2
by 2 matrix.
And where do you see a 2 by 2?
Well, it's like this got
multiplied with this, and what
we have left over is
a 2 by 2 matrix.
So in general-- well actually,
before I go into the general,
let me ask you a question.
Could I have multiplied the
matrices the other way?
Could I have multiplied-- so
this right here that is A
times B, or you can sometimes
write this AB, and we'd bold
it all up so we know
it's matrices.
So could we have multiplied
B times A?
Let me clear this down
here and let's try.
Let's see if we can multiply
B times A.
I think you can already suspect
that, since I'm asking
the question, maybe
you cannot.
Let's clear up some space.
Let's try to do it the other
way around, let's try to
multiply B times A.
So B is minus 1,
0, 2, 3, 5, 5.
And A is-- I'm switching
the order-- 3, 1,
2, minus 2, 0, 5.
And I tend to put brackets
around my matrices.
Some people have these
big parentheses.
It's just all notation; there's
nothing particular
about notation.
So let's see if you can
multiply these.
So we learned that you get the
row information from the first
matrix and the column
information
from the second one.
So this term, in theory, should
be that row times what?
Well, actually, it turns out
that you can multiply them.
Why?
Because this is a 3 by 2, and
this is a 2 by 3, right?
So we're going to take that row
times what?-- times this
column to get the first
term, right?
So what is it going to be?
It's going to be minus 1.
So I actually thought I was
doing a counter example, but
actually because this too is the
same as this, or when you
switch the row this is
the same as this, you
can multiply them.
So I wanted to do a counter
example, but hey.
Let's just work through this
because it never hurts to see
another example.
And you can see that I just
do this on the fly.
So let's do this.
And actually ahead of time, how
large will this matrix be?
Well, this is interesting.
It's actually going to
be a 3 by 3 matrix,
a much bigger matrix.
Let's work it all out, and maybe
you want to pause it and
try it yourself.
This row times this column, so
minus 1 times 3, it's minus 3,
3 times minus 2 is minus 6.
And then it's going to be this
row times this column.
So it's minus 1 times 1 plus
3 times 0, so that's
just minus 1, right?
Because 3 times 0 is 0.
And then, that was that one,
then there's the middle one,
and now we get the
row 1, column 3.
So row 1, column 3.
So it's that row times
this column.
You can tell, this is often
better done by a computer.
Minus 1 times 2 is minus 2 plus
15-- 3 times 5-- so minus
2 plus 5 is 13.
Let's keep going.
So now we're going to take--
I'm sweating, this is so
computationally intensive--
We're taking this row times
each of these columns.
And actually we are going to
learn later that there are
multiple ways of actually
thinking about how this
multiplication happens, even
multiple ways by computer, but
this is the traditional way.
So this row times each of
these columns, right?
So 0, 5, so 0 times 3 plus 5
times minus 2, that's minus
10, and it's 0 times
1 plus 5 times 0.
That's easy, that's 0.
0 times 2 plus 5 times
5 is 25-- almost
there, almost done.
Now we're going to take this row
and multiply it times each
of these columns.
So 2 times 3, that's 6,
plus minus 10, so
that's minus 4, right?
2 times 3 plus 5
times minus 2.
Yes, that's minus 4,
6 minus 10, right?
We have 2 times 1 plus
5 times 0, that's 2.
Then you have 2 times 2 plus 5
times 5, so 4 plus 25 is 29.
And of course that first term,
minus 3 minus 6, so
this is minus 9.
So there you have it.
We multiplied the 3 by 2 matrix
times a 2 by 3 matrix,
and we got a 3 by 3 matrix.
And where did that
3 by 3 come from?
Because this 3 is the number of
rows in the first matrix,
and this 3 is the number of
columns in the second matrix,
which makes sense because we got
our row information from
the first matrix and our column
information from the
second matrix.
Now let me actually show
you an example
that you cannot multiply.
So what if I wanted to multiply
a-- let me do a very
simple example-- what if
I wanted to multiply
the matrix, 2, 1.
And really, all this is,
is a row vector.
And let's say that I wanted to
multiply this times-- I don't
know, so this is a 2 by 1.
So then let me say I want to
multiply this times-- so let
me think of something--
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Now, can I multiply this?
Well, what do we have?
This is a 3 by 2 matrix.
Can I multiply these
two matrices?
Well, what do we have to do?
We get our row information
from here, and our column
information from here--
Oh sorry, this isn't 2 by 1,
this is 1 row, two columns.
This is a 1 by 2, right?
That's a 1 by 2 matrix.
So can you multiply the 1 by
2 times a 3 by 2 matrix?
So we get our row information
from here, so we essentially
have to multiply this by this
times this column to get our
first element, then this
times this column to
get our second element.
And I don't know what happens
from there, but let me-- well,
can we multiply?
Just the way we have defined our
multiplication, or the dot
product, can we multiply?
Let's see, 2 times
1 plus 1 times 2.
Then we don't have anything
to do with the 3.
So the way that we've defined
matrix multiplication, you
cannot multiply these
two matrices.
And you didn't have to go
through that exercise.
You could've looked at the
dimensions, 1 by 2, and this
is a 3 by 2.
This 2 is not equal to this 3,
the number of columns in the
first are not equal to the
number of rows in the second.
So you can not multiply
those two matrices.
So that's something interesting
to think about.
And they're actually examples,
and it's a good exercise for
you to think about it, where
you can multiply A times B,
but you can't multiply
B times A.
So I want you think about
examples where that happens.
But anyway, I'm pushing 15
minutes, and I will see you in
the next video.